hey hi everybody good evening good
afternoon good morning
wherever you are uh welcome to today's
session hosted by the mit club of great
britain
solving the brain pioneering tomorrow's
neuro technologies with
professor ed boyden who we're honored to
have with us
my name is wissam almond theory i'm the
president of the mit club of great
britain
i have a really easy job today i'm going
to be
introducing uh jill critterton in about
a minute here
to introduce professor boyden
and she will also be moderating a q a
session that we'll have
after professor boyden's presentation
um i'd just ask that you
that you listen in we're very lucky to
to have
to have professor boyden i want to
mention that in addition to the mit club
of great britain we've got
participants joining who are members of
various
mit clubs in europe including france
austria
germany switzerland spain
amongst others so welcome to all of you
as well it's great to have you
in this event
just in terms of logistics
as i said professor jill i'm going to
hand over to jill here in a second she's
going to introduce professor boyden
professor boyden will talk through
some a little bit of material and then
go over to a q a session which
jill will moderate as well please put
through your questions in the q and a
box
as well as the comments box either
either works
and what we'll try to do is make sure we
answer as many of those as possible till
the end of the
to the end of the hour so with that
uh it gives me a lot of pressure
pleasure to introduce
jill critterton who's a scientific
advisor advisor at mit's mcgovern
institute
institute and as i said she's going to
be the moderator for today's event
as a neuroscience researcher in the lab
of mit institute
uh professor ann gabriel for the past
two decades
jill's had first-hand experience
collaborating with professor ed boyden
and using
boyden lab tools in her work
unraveling the complex
circuitry of the brain's deepest regions
jill earned her phd in cell biology from
baylor college of
medicine and with that please help me
welcome jill
jill over to you
thank you assam and good evening to the
mit alumni community in great britain
and europe
and good to date to all of you joining
us from the u.s as well
um as we saw mentioned i'm jill
crittenden i'm a scientific advisor at
mit's mcgovern institute for brain
research
and i'm pleased to be the moderator of
today's event we're honored today to
have with us
mit faculty member neuroscientist
engineer
inventor and entrepreneur ed boyden
ed is the y eva tan professor of
neurotechnology at mit
leader of mit synthetic neurobiology
group
a member of the mcgovern institute and
an investigator of the howard hughes
medical institute
he holds appointments in mit's
departments of brain and cognitive
sciences
media arts and sciences and biological
engineering
ed is also a lead principal investigator
at the k lisa yang and hawk etan center
for molecular therapeutics
and co-director of the center for
neurobiological engineering
ed arrived at mit from texas at the age
of 16
and earned his bachelor's and master's
degrees in physics and electrical
engineering and computer science in just
four years his favorite course was the
famous 6270 lego
robot design competition where his robot
got the highest score in the first round
before being soundly defeated in the
second he tried playing piano for a
music scholarship
to be in the debate club and playing
chess in the chess club
but after finishing pretty much in last
place every time
he decided to devote himself to research
he was a founding member of mit's
submarine team
which eight weeks later won the world's
first international underwater
underwater vehicle competition it was
after that when he began to study
quantum computing
and to work on brain modeling which led
to a love of neuroscience
he then went on to stanford where he
earned his phd in neurosciences and
conducted postdoctoral training
before returning to mit in 2006 and
becoming full prep
full faculty member in 2007
ed has been granted nearly 200 patents
with an additional 350 patents pending
he is winner of many notable
international prizes
including the greta lundbeck european
brain prize
and the breakthrough prize he is an
elected member of the national academy
of sciences
national academy of inventors and
american academy of arts and sciences
ed practices meditation almost every
morning a habit that he credits with
helping him balance teaching
running his lab founding companies and
spending time with his two children
edward and athena and srihan a
biomedical engineering professor
at boston university and his wife ed
will speak about his work for about 25
to 30 minutes
and then looks forward to answering
questions from the audience feel free to
type your questions into the q a box at
the bottom of your screen
during or after ed's talk and we'll get
to as many of the questions as we can in
the hour we have together
ed thank you for being with us today and
i now turn the podium over to you
yeah thank you so much jill for the very
kind introduction and song for hosting
uh this event it's a great honor to be
here um
so i direct a group at mit's mcgovern
institute for brain research which
builds tools for helping us
understand and repair the brain and so
over the next half an hour i want to
tell you
a few examples of technologies where we
started with a big problem that nobody
knew how to solve
we invented a technology that could peel
back the scientific mysteries
we distributed it to in some cases
thousands and thousands of research
groups all over the world
who made discoveries and then finally we
would work
to design something practical that we
think could help
with everyday human health
that's very important to us we think
that it's important to delve deeply into
the fundamentals of science but to be
applied
as well i'm gonna try screen sharing
here is this coming through
okay so
uh one of the things that we had to
think about very deeply was why
is the brain so difficult to understand
and to fix and so they're two big
problems
one is space the brain
is in some ways enormous brain cells are
gigantic they can be many centimeters in
spatial
extent but the wiring of the brain these
densely
packed connections between cells the
highways that transfer information from
cell to cell those are nanoscale
and often organized with nanoscale
precision
as you zoom all the way into a brain
cell it's chock full of biomolecules
there are thousands of genes in the
human genome but
those genes encode for biomolecules that
are extremely complicated
and that themselves form a network how
can we see that
but it's worse the time complexity of
the brain is also very daunting
if we care about learning development
the progression of alzheimer's disease
most of the really important
functions of the brain involve at least
one part that takes place over some
extended
period of time sometimes months or even
years
but the fastest fastest events in the
brain are very brief
brain cells generate electrical pulses
that last only a thousandth of a second
so i only half jokingly sometimes say
all we have to do to solve the brain
is to conquer space and time
well one reason of course is to
understand something about the human
condition
what does it mean to have thoughts to
have feelings why
do we do what we do think what we think
feel what we feel
but there's another reason incredibly
trusting and urgent
which are the incredible disease burdens
that are born by people all over the
world
alzheimer's disease stroke spinal cord
injury
addiction the list goes on and on
perhaps over a
billion people around the world have
some kind of condition or disease that's
associated with the brain
and none of these can be cured
and the treatments for the most part are
pretty
pretty partial and with a lot of side
effects
so why is that well i would argue it's
in large part because of the complexity
of the brain
the incredible spatial complexity the
incredible temporal complexity
so today i'll tell you two examples
where one about space
one about time where we've been building
tools to try to confront
head on that complexity
let's start with space so again brain
cells brain networks are gigantic things
biologically speaking
but the wiring of the brain and the
molecules along those wires are
nanoscale
and often organized with nanoscale
precision how can you see something that
complicated
with all the detail that's needed to be
honest we don't know all the changes
that occur in the brain for any brain
disease
or condition this is a big challenge
i think we've all seen pictures like
this uh this is a picture taken by one
of my
um former postdocs now professor at
imperial college london near grossman
an fmri picture of the human brain
these images are very popular because
it's a non-invasive method
of imaging the human brain but those
blobs or voxels are enormous
biologically speaking
they can contain literally billions of
brain cells
and we know from basic neuroscience that
two brain cells even ones that are next
to each other
can be doing completely different things
at the other extreme are microscopes
this is how brain cells were found in
the first place
um many years ago over 100 years ago
but here's the problem light which is
what these microscopes use
has a finite size or wavelength and
unfortunately
it's about a tenth or so the size
of a neural cell body so it's not enough
to see the nanoscale wiring
or molecules of the brain what can we do
well in our group we often try to do the
opposite of what everybody's doing
for literally 300 years people been
using some kind of magnification device
to magnify images like a lens to magnify
images
of biological objects like cells
we started wondering well if that's hit
its limit
what if we take the brain and make it
physically bigger
what if we physically magnify the brain
so that's kind of a strange way to think
about things that's kind of how we
we generate ideas in our group and we
start thinking about
what can we borrow that could allow us
to do that
well it turns out an mit professor
tayuji tanaka
in the late 1970s early 1980s was
studying swellable polymers
the same kind of stuff you find in baby
diapers and so
in this movie is a little animation we
made of what a swallowable polymer like
sodium polyacrylate does when you add
water the water goes in
via osmosis the polymer threads shown as
white lines
start to stretch and within a few
minutes
as millions of kids experiment on every
day
you get this thousand-fold volumetric
increase in size
so we started thinking what if we could
chemically
install a dense spider web-like mesh of
polymer
inside the brain not just inside brain
cells but also
outside brain cells in between all those
biomolecules and
inside those wires that i told you about
earlier
well we figured out a chemical way of
doing that we can chemically synthesize
this dense spider web-like meshes
swallowable polymer
inside an outside brain cells and to do
it extremely
densely and precisely
so then we can soften the specimen
through adding detergents for example
we add water and that swallowable
polymer will absorb the water
but this time because the swallowable
polymer is inside the brain cells
and permeating throughout the brain the
brain itself will be
enlarged all those molecules are being
pulled apart from each other
every cell is becoming bigger and the
space between cells is also
becoming bigger it's like you drew a
picture of the brain on a balloon
and blow up the balloon it's the same
picture
but all the ink molecules are farther
apart of course this does not work on
living things
it only can work on preserved brain
tissues
so we call this invention expansion
microscopy
panel b shows a piece of the mouse brain
before we expand it
panel c is the same piece of mouse brain
about a day and a half later
and we blew it up a hundred times in
volume about four and a half times in
each direction
here's a little movie of the actual
adding of water
to the polymerized brain so we add the
water right there
this movie sped up it takes more like an
hour than a minute
but i thought i would save you the time
and just show you the sped up version
and i hope you can see this piece of the
brain growing before your very eyes
so that's what we see when we are zoomed
out
this is a macroscopic piece of brain
what's happening at the molecular scale
well we think we're pulling all the
biomolecules those nanoscale building
blocks that make up cells
we're pulling all the biomolecules apart
from each other
so on the left is a cartoon of a single
brain cell
on the right is a cartoon of the same
brain cell if we pull all the
biomolecules apart
so two molecules that are touching are
now some distance apart from each other
and all the molecules have had their
distances scaled up by some linear
factor
what that means is now you can take
images
with molecular or nanoscale precision
and to do it inexpensively and
powerfully
we are now taking brain circuitry
and you can express glowing proteins
from jellyfish and coral in them
using genetic engineering tricks here's
an example of a piece of brain
where we did that the different colors
are literally corresponding to different
colors
of the brain and that's been done for a
while
for us and proteins have been used in
neuroscience for decades
but now because we expand the brain we
can look at the fine wiring
of the brain and the molecules along
those wires
and so one of my hopes is that through
color coding cells
expanding them and imaging them we can
trace the neural circuitry of the brain
i think with maybe even enough precision
that we could try to simulate
brain computations on a computer
i would love from a basic science
standpoint to know
how a decision or an emotion is being
computed by the brain i would love
to be able to pinpoint exactly where in
the brain
a brain condition or disorder begins
we've now transferred this technology to
literally thousands of researchers all
over the world
in universities and non-profit settings
where they're imaging
all sorts of stuff you could argue this
is the first
democratized accessible method where
anybody can do nano imaging
no equipment required beyond what most
scientists already have access to
now as i mentioned the beginning of the
talk we invent a tool
in this case a way of physically
expanding biological specimens
we share it with people who make
discoveries
can we then bring to the world practical
health advancing applications well many
doctors started to contact us
in many countries including throughout
the us the uk
europe many of the leading causes of
death
you could save more wise if you catch
the disease earlier for example can you
catch a cancer before it spreads
now why is it so hard to detect a
disease
early well early in a disease the
changes are quite small
literally they're hard to see i'll give
you an example
many doctors contacted us and asked if
we could work on breast cancer
early in breast cancer doctors disagree
when they look at a biopsy
about the diagnosis up to 50 percent
half of the time
they asked could we make the biopsy
physically larger
if so could you catch a cancer earlier
well we expanded here's an example of an
actual expanded human
breast cancer biopsy we expanded these
biopsies and
used these biopsies evaluated by a team
of doctors
to train a machine learning algorithm to
classify
the biopsy images when we use expanded
specimens
the machine learning did a lot better
than when we used regular old
unexpanded specimens so now we're trying
to
work with many people all over the world
uh
including a team that's emerging across
the uk and europe
to see if we can expand pathology
specimens
and understand diseases at a more
detailed level and make early detection
more practical so that's the example i
want to tell you about space
we saw a big problem biology and
medicine are fundamentally nanoscale
sciences but
everything's too small to see using
technology
we invented a technology expansion
microscopy so that anybody could do nano
imaging
we deployed it into the world and helped
lots of people make discoveries
and finally we're helping design
practical applications
like machine learning strategies that
take advantage of the incredible
resolution
afforded by expansion
of course the limitation of expansion is
that it does not work on living things
and so
in the second half of this presentation
i want to tell you about time
how do we understand and repair the
brain across
all of its temporal complexity well of
course many people have come up with
ways to try to stimulate the brain
drugs electrical stimulation and so
forth but they're not very precise
drugs or electrical stimulation methods
will affect all the cells of the brain
in unpredictable ways sometimes
so in our group we've been working on a
tool set now in use by thousands of
scientists all over the world
that we call optogenetics opto because
we use light
and genetics because as you'll see we
use genetically encoded products
to make brain cell sense light
the core idea is the following what if
we could basically make little solar
panels
and install them in brain cells shine
light on the brain cell
and the solar panels will convert it to
electricity
we can bring light into the brain
because the brain does not feel pain
in model organisms like mice so the big
question was
how do we make or find these solar
panels
well it turns out all over the tree of
life you can find molecules that convert
light
into electrical signals here's a
single-celled green algae
and it navigates around bodies of water
to photosynthesize well
how does it sense light well it has an
eye spot that we just zoomed into
and the eye spot is chock full of
proteins that convert light into
electrical signals
when these proteins are hit by light
they open up a small
pore and transport ions charged
particles from one side of the membrane
to the other so
i started wondering could we take the
genes that encode for these proteins
put them into brain cells and see if the
brain manufactures these proteins
these proteins have been discovered by
many scientists including many
from europe and in the united states
well we got lucky the protein is encoded
by a small gene
we can take the gene and transplant it
using
conventional tricks from the field of
gene therapy into a brain cell
the brain cell will then manufacture the
protein
that by itself was quite surprising for
all we know this
gene from algae could have been toxic
right but brain cells manufactured it
just fine
and installed them in the right place
then when we shine light blue light to
be specific
those light activated proteins would be
activated
and we could drive electrical pulses
much like the kind that are happening in
your brain right now
as i say these words
well how do we use it we can put
again using tricks from the field of
gene therapy the molecule
into some brain cells and not others so
for
example there are small star-shaped
brain cells called basket cells because
of their shape
and you can use gene therapy tricks
in order to make just those cells and
not their neighbors
express the light-sensitive molecule
then shine light on the brain the
molecules on these cells will be
activated
and just those cells will be driven to
fire electrical pulses
their neighbors will not be directly
affected by the light
so again we perceived a need to control
the brain
we invented a technology that we call
optogenetics
next we gave it to people all over the
world to make discoveries
i'll just give you one example by my mit
colleague leeway tsai
she used the optogenetic tools to
discover that if you drive the brain
at a specific frequency 40 times a
second
and she did this in mice engineered to
get alzheimer's like symptoms
amazingly their brains would get better
blood flow would increase all sorts of
interesting health promoting
effects occur amyloid plaques would go
away
her team went on to discover that you
can induce the same brain rhythms these
40 hertz rhythms
through visual stimuli and auditory
stimuli
basically a movie and so now
we are actually doing trials uh
of effectively movies to try to see if
we can help people
with alzheimer's disease
many people are using the technology of
optogenetics to try to discover other
health promoting
activity patterns now
in this case we were very lucky you
could use
light and sound delivered to the eyes
and ears to create that activity pattern
but what if there are parts of the brain
or
brain rhythms that you want to induce
that are not so easy to create
well nir grossman is now a professor at
imperial college in london
when he was a postdoc in my group worked
on a technology
where we deliver electric fields in
patterns to the brain
and if you use the right timing and the
right spatial distribution of electric
fields
we found that we could actually focus
the effects of electric fields to deep
brain targets
so we're thinking very translationally
now in the design phase hey we now know
that brain activity patterns can help
now we're trying to design different
non-invasive ways
using our eyes or ears or in this case
electric fields delivered from outside
the brain
to hit those deep targets
option genetics is being used to make
lots of discoveries i'll just mention
one example which i like because there's
a cool movie i can show you
this is work from chris fiorillo's group
they wanted to know
could they study dopamine and learning
now dopamine is very well studied it's
often called the pleasure center of the
brain
by the popular press but as we all know
it's much more complicated than that
uh in chris's group they made these
dopamine cells express the light
activated protein
implanted an optical fiber connected to
a laser and aim the optical fiber at
these cells deep deep in the brain
this is in mice and then ask
if mice go to a certain point in a box
they get a pulse of light
if the mice go to a second point in the
box they don't get a pulse of light
what will the mouse do well here's the
result
the mouse goes pokes his nose into a
sensor gets a pulse of light
does it again gets another pulse of
light you can see the blue light
lighting up the optical fiber here
i think you're getting the picture
basically the mouse is working for light
so many groups are using this technology
to prove that a certain set of cells in
the brain
when you activate it is enough to
trigger
some kind of effect
well in our group we've been working to
further the technology
all over the tree of life you can find
molecules that convert light into
electrical signals
and we now have tools that allow us to
turn neurons on or off with light so
these are now being used all over the
world to study
how the brain works and actually
several groups in france and switzerland
are working together and in the uk i
believe at this point
to do clinical trials of these for
blindness can you help people see
when they've lost their ability to see
in short many people who are blind have
lost the photoreceptor cells in their
eye
and so uh this group which i think is
now in phase two of clinical trials
um has shown that they can take our
molecules
put them into remaining cells in the eye
and get safe expression
so again you can kind of see a pattern
here we see a problem
we invent a tool we give it to lots of
people and with those discoveries we can
try to design
practical applications that can go out
into the world
i'll just want to note one last thing
here
we want to watch the brain in action as
well and so this is kind of where
we're heading in terms of new technology
areas
with optogenetics we were very lucky the
natural world evolved these molecules
that convert light into electrical
signals
and we were just so lucky that they were
safe and effective in neurons
for watching the brain in action
remember the expansion method lets us
map the brain but it won't work on a
living brain
if we want to watch the brain while it's
computing
we have to invent a new way of building
these tools
and so one thing we're doing is building
robots that can do evolution
we have built robots that can screen
many genes
and pick out ones that have features we
want
in a recent project that our wonderful
supporter lisa yang has helped us
initiate we're now trying to see if we
can use this to do bio mining
and to identify new molecules from the
natural world
that might help cure people of many
kinds of conditions
but in this first demo we show that we
could evolve by screening through
libraries of genes
a molecule that converts sort of the
opposite of optogenetics it converts
neural signals into light with
optogenetics we convert light into
neural signals
now we're trying to see can we watch the
brain in action
and so we made a molecule that glows
when a neuron
is active you can use a microscope like
the one in the upper left
and image brain cells as they compute
another thing we're doing is to try to
see if we can monitor many signals at
once
in a living cell this is tricky
because there are thousands of genes in
the genome and they encode for
so many different molecules wouldn't it
be great if we could watch
all of them in action at once but how
can you do that in a living
brain cell if we could do that we could
see how
all these gene products interact to
generate life
and we can see how they go wrong in a
disease
well the usual way is you try to make an
indicator that glows with a certain
color
like green or red but there's only so
many colors
well we've been working on a strategy
to have brain cells report different
signals
from different points what if some
points in a cell
could broadcast one kind of information
and other points in a cell can broadcast
a different kind of information
that's what you see in this little
cartoon here
while the cell is alive each point in
the cell will broadcast a different
signal and then once you're done with
the experiment
you can use all sorts of staining and
imaging tricks to figure out
which reporters were at each
point reporters such as the kind that we
made
through evolving with that robot that i
told you earlier
i'll take a long story short we can do
that we can engineer proteins so they
will actually self-assemble
into little dots at different points in
a cell
while the cells alive they will tell us
what's going on
for a given signal at a given point
maybe this cartoon will be helpful when
the cell's alive
you see lots of green dots they'll be
turning on or off as the cell does
its thing when we're done we can stain
the green dots with different stains and
figure out what
signals were actually coming from those
dots
well here's an example here we have a
neuron
at the top right of this image
and you see lots of green dots the
yellow squares in the upper right are
zoomed in
at the bottom images in k and l
in the green images you see lots of
green dots when the cells align they'll
be blinking on or off
we have four different glowing reporters
in the cell now they're all green so
how can you tell them apart right well
after you're done the experiment you can
do the staining
and that's when you see the red purple
and yellow and blue images on the right
hand side of k
and l in short you can see
many signals at once from a living cell
because they are being broadcast from
different points in the cell
and we can do this with more than four
indicators at once
so let's summarize we've been building
tools to let us
map the brain by making the brain
physically larger
to control the brain by adding in
molecules that convert light to
electrical energy
and observing the brain by building
robots to evolve new molecules that glow
when cells are having certain signals in
them
and figuring out how to use many at once
how do we bring these all together of
course one benefit is we give away these
tools to thousands of groups all over
the world
but i'm also very interested in trying
to understand how entire
brains work to do that we want to make
maps of entire small brains like worms
and fish
i would love to simulate an entire small
brain
in a computer the history of biology and
medicine says solve something small
completely the first genome to be
sequenced was not the human genome
but of a small virus if we can
understand how entire brains work
together
to generate decisions and emotions i
think that could have
ramifications throughout all of
neuroscience including and up to
the human brain but over a more short
time scale
i hope i've been able to explain to you
in a couple different contexts how this
model
invented tool helped people make
discoveries design
practical inventions that can help with
human health
and get them out into the world how this
business model
is a powerful model for innovating in
bioengineering
in academia and as i mentioned one of
our newest projects just officially
launched about a month ago
which uh lisa yang helped initiate in
our group at the mcgovern institute
is to do bio mining you know the
optogenetics was sort of
an accidental example here's a set of
molecules from the natural world
that lets us control the brain with
light
how many other treasures are out there
waiting to be discovered
if we can use our robots to accelerate
that discovery
and do on purpose what before everybody
did accidentally
that could bring many new technologies
in to help with human health
in these short form talks i don't have
time to acknowledge all the people who
contributed
but i want to end on this slide where
many people in our group and our alumni
in the top part of the slide
and an even longer list of collaborators
all over the world
including many in the uk and europe in
the middle part of the slide this is
truly a global effort everybody talks
about interdisciplinary research
nowadays but
neurotechnology is omnidisciplinary
today i talk about electric fields
genome mining
robots chemistry you know there's no
part of the scientific enterprise that's
not represented
we always share all our tools as freely
as possible so our website sits
neuro.org talks about how to get access
to them
and we're always looking to learn about
new problems we can help with so don't
hesitate to drop me a line my email
ed boyden mit edu is always open
and with that happy to take questions
thank you ed i'll um help with some of
the
uh questions that have come up in that
in the chat
so um there are several that actually to
me seem related
one is is about um
whether the 40 hertz frequency that was
used to improve
alzheimer's disease symptoms in mice um
would be should be a different
frequency used for for humans for
example do you need to scale up in some
way
and the other questions that i see as
related are can you see
firing of an a single neuron which of
course i know
that you you can see that well but how
important is that depending on
whether you're looking at a big human
brain or a small mouse brain where the
computation's
computations may be very different
because frequencies travel differently
across these different
size brains and then the a big question
is how close do you think we are to
actually understanding the brain
and so how close do you think we are to
understanding the mouse brain
and how does that relate to
understanding the human brain
um so i'd love to hear your thoughts
about all these questions
yeah great questions let's start with
the 40 hertz so this project which
leeway sai has been leading at mit with
great help from our group on the
technology and inventing side
um uh we have actually under her group's
leadership begun human trials
um and uh it's early days
but um this frequency band called the
gamma band
does seem to be although the exact
frequency might differ from species of
species
but it does seem to be conserved across
many brain regions
and many species so that's one hope that
leads to the idea that
doing clinical trials could be of
importance
and relevant although you know we still
are in the process of conducting them
now what about single neurons well it's
a good question
on the one hand biology is very robust
on the other hand biology shows that
small perturbations can lead to very
unpredictable outcomes a few people
have used our optogenetic tools and
other tools developed by other groups
to ask the question what can one brain
cell do
now none of this has been done in the
human brain but there are several
studies from mice which have about 100
million neurons ballpark
and from rats which have perhaps 400
million neurons the 500 million neurons
ballpark and what they've shown is that
if you stimulate
one neuron just one neuron out of those
hundreds of millions
with the right pattern sometimes you can
change the whole brain
so i think what we're realizing is the
brain
is sort of mysterious you
can actually have great power for one
neuron
on the other hand the brain is robust in
some ways as well
one of my hopes with the simulations is
that we could actually try to simulate
whether there are certain hot spots in
the brain where if you stimulate them
you can change much of the brain for the
better
about a hundred thousand people have had
deep brain stimulators implanted
and in deep brain stimulation
there is an attempt to try to stimulate
very small regions of the brain
and find regions that can affect many
regions for the better
but many of these sites have been found
through serendipity
let's see what was the third question i
forgot what it was
oh i thought you did a great job of
integrating all those questions and i
want to be able to get to a few more
because i know you're
working on covid19 as well and one
person had asked whether you're
addressing long covet and i'll add to
that um whether you're addressing the
mysteries of covid
effects of on the brain yeah
so finding a virus in the brain
is a difficult thing because it's also a
nanoscale problem right these viruses
are tiny
we've actually started recently uh
another collaboration with leeway sai
where
um because we were working with our own
alzheimer's and alzheimer's patients
unfortunately have been one of the
vulnerable populations for covet
especially if they're in an
assisted living facility we have started
working with her to see if the expansion
method
which lets us pinpoint nanoscale things
like viruses
and extended tissues like the brain if
we can
study where covet is in the brain if it
is there
and what cells it affects so these
studies are just getting going
we've only done a few pilot experiments
but my hope is that over the spring we
can
start to pinpoint where covet is
what cell types it's affecting what the
state is is it an active virus
is it the byproduct of a virus and to
understand a bit more about what if
anything is happening in the brain
because
there's a lot of work on covid
and brain symptoms but we don't know
much about what if anything is happening
in the brain itself
there are also many people who work on
of course cover the rest of the body
and although we don't study that in the
group we are trying to help other people
set up expansion
so they can pinpoint exactly where a
virus is
in a complex 3d tissue but again those
experiments are very early stage
so another important question that came
into the chat about your recent
work in which you're building these
scaffolds so that you can look at the
activity of
many different proteins in a single cell
simultaneously
and i know you guys did a lot of control
experiments um
and uh it's such an important question
how
do you know that you're not disrupting
the
where where proteins are and i like the
way that the person who
who opposed the question said similar to
the uncertainty principle
yeah it's a great question in fact i
trained as a physicist before switching
into biology so i make the analogy
with the uncertainty principle as well
um
that's a great question yeah so joe yeah
as you were noting uh
there's no substitute for doing great
control experiments in any technology
for looking at
or controlling a specific function could
affect other functions
and so uh in this study where we're
trying to monitor many
living signals at different points
within a living cell
we did do a lot of controls we asked is
the speed of the signal changing is the
amplitude of the signal changing
is the natural physiology of the cell
altered
is there cell death or inflammation or
dna damage we have a long list of things
to look for
and so the answer is we did not see any
overt changes
of these kinds now does this mean that
there are no changes of any kind
well when one is applying the tools one
really has to say okay i'm going to look
at the cells with the
tool but also to do experiments to show
that the tool itself is not changing
that function so for example
you know you might have cells where you
give a drug or you might have a disease
state or whatever
and doing a subset of experiments
without the tool there may be testing it
through different means
or using the tool but delivering the
drug and not the drug so you can see
you know what is the drug specifically
inducing as opposed to the tool
are important controls but so far we've
been pretty pretty pleased
um we haven't seen any overt problems
and that might be because
we work very hard to make the technology
bio-orthogonal what that means is the
scaffolds we use to put the
sensors into the little dots they're
human design
they're meant to be different from the
natural molecules in the cell
and in fact our collaborator amy keating
in mit biology
is one of the pioneers of these
synthetic self-assembling peptides and
she's one of the key authors on our
paper
and so working with her um we
were very careful to try to pick
molecules that were human designed
to do the clustering hoping therefore
that they would
interfere less with the cell than if we
picked a natural molecule
and that may have helped but of course
there's no substitute for good
control experiments that's a really
interesting idea i didn't know that that
makes me see it in a whole different
light
where you have these really separate
categories that are
serving to tell you what's going on in a
in a separate part which is the real
functioning cell
so one of the questions that came up and
i'll just read it directly because this
is not my area of expertise but it is
yours and i think it
leads into how another question that
somebody had asked me earlier is how
does your knowledge of electrical
engineering and computer science relate
to your
fundamental understanding in the life
sciences and so the person's question is
what is the most general abstraction
to understand how the brain does
computation
what is the most basic unit of
computation how can we systematically
build a computational model of a brain
perhaps in an automated way with
massively parallel experiments
yeah that's a great question yeah so ios
course six and eight
mit computer science and physics and so
i love the idea of an abstraction layer
beyond a certain point you don't need
the detail because you can
use higher level concepts as your
building blocks to think about
and repair a computer of course
computers were designed by people so the
extraction layer is explicit
there's lots of zeros and ones but you
can also write high level code and
make an internet app or whatever without
having to know anything about the zeros
and ones that are the fundamental
representation
okay so for the brain the tricky part is
we don't know for sure
where the extraction layer is
and there are neuroscientists at mit you
study single
molecules or you know molecules that
synapses and he would never look at the
circuit
and other people study large scale
circuits even in the human brain
and never think about the molecule this
is one reason why we built the tools
that we built
we want to help scientists cross those
levels of description
expansion microscopy my dream is we
could image an entire brain
but not lose sight of all those
molecules and so on and so forth for the
other tools that i talked about
now what is this going to do practically
though this is one reason why i really
want to study an entire small brain like
a fish or a worm or something
we know that fish and worms can make
rudimentary decisions and exhibit
rudimentary emotion-like behaviors as
well if we can understand some
fundamental principles about how
the molecules in the cells work together
and how the cells in the brain work
together
to generate these dynamics we might
learn some very fundamental principles
about how
cells work together in networks and then
we might be able to draw some
conclusions right
look we don't need to look at every
protein and where it's found
but this thing you really need to pay
attention to
and i think my dream would be to see the
molecular world of neuroscience which is
an
entire very interesting field and the
systems world of neuroscience where
people focus more on the circuits and
the electrical activities
to see them merge in part driven by
tools but in part driven by what
insights we can learn
from whole brain imaging
um one person had a question about
mapping which i think
what you're just talking about feeds
into that question really
well they wanted to know about mapping
in worms worm brain
human brain mouse brain and of course
some things are very well mapped out
right like the worm brain we know where
every neuron is going to go and the
basic shape it's going to
make but that doesn't
give you insight into how much things
can vary from worm to worm
at an individual level based upon
experience for example
so could you talk about what you think
the fundamental differences are between
mapping
big brains and the worm brain
sure so we picked the species we worked
on quite carefully
the worm has 302 neurons and the
connections are
are somewhat stereotype from worm to
worm we now know there's some
variability
but um but one big question is how
variable are they
and this is where the expansion method
becomes very useful is that so now
people would spend years to reconstruct
one worm or a couple worms
they would cut the worm into literally
10 000 sections
and image them with expensive electron
microscopes
but just this past summer we showed that
we could expand an entire worm
and image it using an inexpensive
ordinary microscope
so my hope is by the end of this year we
will show that we can color code
the cells of the worm expand it and make
maps on a worm to worm bases
now a zebrafish a larval zebrafish has
about a hundred thousand neurons
ballpark a thousand times more than the
worm
a mouse has about a thousand times more
than the larval zebrafish
and a human has ballpark about a
thousand times more than the mouse
so i hope we can do with small brains is
to map many of them
and we can ask questions like how does
the wiring differ from brain to brain
how do the cell types differ do those
differences
associate with differences in the
computations and behaviors
my hope is we can build theories of
brain function
we can then test these because we have
many collaborating
students who work between our group and
other groups at the mcgovern institute
and beyond
we can test those ideas through
perturbations of the mouse spring
the problem with the mouse brain of
course is it's too big to image the
whole thing right now
and even making a map of every uh
connection in the mouse brain people
speculate it could cost between 100
million and 1 billion
us dollars so you know we probably we
want to work a bit harder on the
technology and make it better before
spending that much money
on one mouse brain so in summary let's
make maps of many small brains
let's make maps of part of larger brains
like mice and humans
we can make theories of how neurons work
together using small brains but then
test them on the larger brains
and see what general principles of brain
function emerge
thank you another question that's come
in that i think
uh is such an important one and you
probably also have some experience with
your physics background where
experimentalists and theorists are
very distinct fields whereas in biology
the person's question is do you think
the next
big breakthrough will will come from
understanding new methods of acquiring
experimental data
or methods of analyzing the experimental
data that we're already able to acquire
yeah it's a good question we obviously
need both
and uh it's great that we have so many
fantastic experimental as well as
computational colleagues at
the mcgovern institute and and
throughout mit
um here's why i think we need both
if you don't see or control a biological
system with sufficient resolution
you might be missing out and right now
most of us in neuroscience think of the
brain cell
as a fundamental unit of computation but
there are others like mark harnett at
the mcgovern institute who work on how
parts of cells
compute how do we know for sure what
detail to ignore
and what detail is necessary so being
able to
image and control with enough resolution
is very
very important now on the other hand the
more resolution the more detail
the more things there are to analyze as
well
and so in the coming years our hope is i
think to make connections with machine
learning and ai
with different statistical methods with
different dynamical methods
and to see how those can help with the
data analysis you suppose you can make a
map
of an entire small brain what branch of
mathematics do you need to simulate it
or to analyze the network
well there's so much mathematics out
there right and this is something that i
hope in the coming years
uh we at mit can make a concrete
contribution to so for example
um last year well before before covet
hit
i met with the director of mit's new
college of computing
um and we started asking hey are there
ways to build more connections between
fundamental computer science and brain
data and these are early stage
discussions
um but it's very clear that
to extract the meaning from biological
data is challenging
but let's look at past successes right
i'd love to look at the history of
biology and medicine
because it can sometimes give you a
little bit of a hint to the future
and one of the areas of great success
has been genomics
so you know first people sequence a
small genome
a virus then there was a big push to
make the human genome but it cost like a
billion us dollars to do that
then next gen sequencing came along and
now sequencing genomes is
much much much much cheaper and then
finally we have bioinformaticists who
are
analyzing lots of genomes and comparing
them and looking at regulatory regions
and mutations and this is
linked to schizophrenia and that's like
to and so on and so forth
um uh and and maybe there's something
similar that might be happening in
neuroscience in the years to come
okay it's hard to analyze the brain but
here's a way to do it
let's do it for a small brain hey let's
scale it up by building
what the next gen equivalent of next-gen
sequencing
and now let's start comparing and mining
and analyzing it
and so my hope is over the next five to
ten years that kind of
innovative culture which is a very
mit-ish thing to do
will emerge and um and that
the kinds of problems in neuroscience
that we currently look at and say wow
that looks pretty impossible
will start to to fall into the realm of
the tractable
the next question i see is about whether
the type of work that you do might make
cognitive neuroscience obsolete and i'm
sure that you
have some interesting insight to that
because you have such close colleagues
in the mcgovern institute who are
cognitive scientists
and how do you see your work interfacing
with theirs or
will you know if you understand every
last bit of
how each molecule works in the brain
would it make cognitive neuroscience
obsolete
i think cognitive neuroscience is very
very important and let me give you an
example of why i think even if you could
map
every molecule and circuit you still
need
a way of thinking about the function
suppose
we see a pattern of activity in the
brain um we see a sequence that
occurs over and over again what does it
do
how do we know whether it's important or
just some random noise
and so i think what we need is better
behavioral neuroscience
and better technologies to um
to go after what you might call meta
behavior these internal states that
contribute to behavior
but the linkage might be remote you
suppose i'm daydreaming right now which
i'm not
but suppose i'm daydreaming i might just
be sitting here and nobody by watching
me will know what's going on in my brain
but three days from now maybe some
imagined idea i had will change my
behavior i'll bet
i was daydreaming about you know some
crazy idea and bam now suddenly i go and
do it right
so it's very clear that behavior is
important and i would say the majority
of neuroscientists right now are very
behavioral
but i think we also have to look inside
and look at internal states
and look at representations that are not
immediately linked to behavior and
that's where the cognitive science is so
important
so to summarize if we care about
function we care about behavior but
behavior is just the tip of the iceberg
right there's that roiling sea of
thought and emotion
that happens all the time only a small
part of which ever rises to the level of
overt behavior we see somebody move or
do something
and i think we need to build much better
internal representations of what's going
on in the brain and so
yeah across mcgovern and and throughout
the brain and cognitive science
department
i think there's a very fruitful
intersection between the behaviorists
the cognitive and internal process
focused people
the circuitry people and hopefully more
and more of the mechanistic molecular
stuff as well
although as noted earlier new tools are
probably needed to help stitch it all
together
and probably our last question because
of time is
someone asks about how you see the
future of treating brain disorders some
combination of dbs
and pharmacology that are already known
to work something totally new
um yeah great question
well there haven't been any cures for
brain diseases
in the sense that you know you can give
somebody penicillin and
uh you know the the infection will go
away
um yeah it's a good question
i think it's a difficult thing to answer
because
very often
the deep complexity of the brain means
we're going to be surprised
i mean if you told me 10 years ago that
i would be helping
a group with trials of effectively
movies for alzheimer's i would say wow
that sounds pretty ludicrous
but you know you know it's like the
the the four-part story i mentioned we
invent new tools people try things out
make discoveries then we help design
practical versions and then they get out
into the world you know that
that that leads to a different way of
thinking
let's take a step back you know i think
a lot of people think like basic science
right
i'm going to discover something or
translational work we're going to cure
people
i would argue there's a third angle
which is innovation
built a tool to accelerate the science
and put the translational work on
firmer ground but it could lead to very
unpredictable outcomes
and i think we're going to find is that
the future of neural therapeutics is
going to be
full of serendipity and full of very
unpredictable outcomes that will help
people
thank you so much i'm going to turn it
back over to wissam to say his uh thank
yous and goodbyes
great thank you jill and uh just leaves
me with
very little to say but just a big big
big thank you to
both jill critterton and professor ed
boyden
for just a fantastic talk i i know i
speak for a number of you or i say
i can't remember the last time i've
learned so much in such a short period
of time personally
and i genuinely mean that so thank you
professor
big thank you to all of you for joining
from the club of great britain and all
around the different clubs in europe and
um and i i know we're going to try
really hard when the world goes back to
normal at some point
to get professor boyden over
to the uk on one of his trips and do a
talk in person uh he's
i know he's in the uk a lot you said
professor for for other
reasons and so we'll try to catch you on
one of those
um again just to close thank you very
much everybody
and if you have any follow-ups or any
feedback or anything please don't
hesitate to email the
mit club of gb and we'll make sure we
get the
questions or thoughts or feedback to the
to the right person
have a very good morning afternoon or
evening take care